he's going to tell us something that we
really want to know how to become a
millionaire by cheating
um so I decided my name is Nikon and I'm
going to be talking about how to cheat
at Who Wants To Be A Millionaire and
maybe along the way show non-hardness of
Gap and CSP and this is trying to work
with Eric allender on their calendars
day and also Rahul alanka
okay so what what am I what is this talk
what am I even gonna talk about
I just want to like get this across from
the beginning
I do not support cheating despite the
title my goal here is not to encourage
or teach you how to cheat but rather to
talk about a hopefully fun toy problem
from the dymax are you under Eric
allender's mentorship with uh Rahul
alango a few summers ago
sorry maybe uh maybe tomorrow at CC
talks for uh how to how to become a
millionaire
but uh yeah and I'll briefly mention how
it relates to showing non-hardness of a
gap mktp under restricted types of
Productions
okay so just a quick show of hands so
who here wants to become a millionaire
okay fantastic
great so the good news for you is that
there's sure the reason why everybody in
California Wants to Be a Millionaire
you're either a millionaire or you're a
renter
exactly so
so maybe you you know the good news is
maybe you find yourself on on the show
there's this game show called Who Wants
To Be A Millionaire and they ask you a
bunch of trivia questions and if you get
you know essentially all of them right
you you get some chance to earn a earn a
million dollars which is which is
fantastic and as you said you want to
become a millionaire so imagine you're
the person in this game show
the bad news is that you haven't
prepared at all for this uh for this
game show
which you know oh well
but the good news is that you have some
really good friends
and these friends are willing to prepare
on your behalf to some degree
so what do I mean
so here's some form of preparation
let's assume that all of the trivia
questions that are going to get asked in
this game show come from some master
book of questions and answers that has
like P Pages total it's from some big
book it's a master book that is p pages
and if you want to think Super
concretely think of p as being let's say
a thousand
you have uh and friends you know good
for you and let's say for concreteness
let's say N is a 50.
and you know your friends are helpful
but they're only uh boundedly helpful
they're only going to help you uh learn
you know they're only going to help you
by each reading our Pages out of this uh
you know this book so learning the
questions and the answers
um on on R out of P pages and let's say
um to be to be concrete
so maybe you're already worried that you
know 50 times 200 is already bigger than
a thousand so what's going on but there
are some rules to the cheating
what are what are the rules to this
cheating
so yeah friends can each memorize
answers of our Pages ahead of time
for every question you can pull all of
your friends
but and this is crucial you and your
friends do not know which page the
question is from
and your friends are only going to have
a correctness guarantee if they've
happened to read the page that the
question is on
and otherwise they have no correctness
guarantee they could answer correctly
incorrectly there's no guarantee
no just arbitrary we're still yeah
adversarial if you want
okay so so how can you and your friends
strategize to always win
so that's to be sure
we don't know the density of the pages
perfect
if I give you another page how many
friends
I mean you can so I guess the question
is how to strategize like maybe you tell
certain friends to read certain subsets
at all yeah yeah so hopefully I'll make
it a little bit more clear what I'm
talking about if you say your friends
don't know what page it's from they'll
know if it's one of their names no
they don't know if I've seen it but
they've like they've read so many pages
that they just if they've happened to
have read it yeah they will say the
correct answer but otherwise they could
be arbitrarily and even they don't know
I don't know how they will answer they
don't have control over what they think
so they have control over what they
answered but imagine they've read so
many pages they're so tired they only
just know the correct answer but they
know like for the questions that they've
read they know the correct answers for
everything else they think
yeah yeah
sure
I am one of the friends sure
I read the 200 faces if I make a
question in these 200 phases I will
answer correct that's right
of 1000 equations exactly
maybe another way of saying it is your
friend read all the pages but they only
understood 200 of them
that's a better way
yeah exactly so we'll get to that yeah
you can we can selectively choose which
brands are good to remember in which
pages
and I know which which fans will that
vote exactly so you know which friends
have read which pages and you can all uh
agree on something beforehand foreign
friends they each read some subset of
pages at Subway and uh you know the size
of each side is a MSR
here and Friends they're characterized
by the set of pages they they read
let's say there's some trivia question q
that pops up
it's on some page I'll just call it page
of queue somewhere from from page one
through p
the question is going to be fed to uh to
you and you know all of your friends
these friends in this process of reading
the pages have effectively learned
functions F sub I so we'll say your I
friend has learned a function f sub I
um that takes in a question and outputs
in the case if he wants to be a
millionaire it's a multiple choice game
with you know A B C or D so they put out
put out some letter
and I just want to emphasize you know
these functions the only guarantee these
functions have is that they're correct
when the you know corresponding page of
the question is something that the I
threatened has read
these answers get fed to you
and then you somehow have to combine all
of these answers from your friends to
I'll put some final final multiple
choices here which one answers would
you know uh yeah which friend is giving
Which answer that's right
but the question is
yeah you don't know not your friends
neither of you know uh yeah either you
know because if your friends did know
then they could just correct their
answers say I don't know or give the
right answer and that's not the that's
not the model we're in here
and any more questions I'm happy to
clarify the model it's uh it is a bit
confusing so the ones that are that
don't know it somehow they know
you can think of it that way but uh if
they're if they're honest friends yeah I
mean depending on how you want to think
of it but there's no guarantee that or
they don't know that they're giving the
wrong answer
do I know in which way it is the
question yes or no
so yeah for me now I'm playing the game
okay all right do I know uh in which
space is the question yeah excellent but
so if I don't know anything I don't know
actually if it's of them already know
exactly
I'm just trying to understand why the
players should not remember the pages
but it's maybe too much information for
them to to know in some sense and yeah
I'll mention the application later on
so you're bad or something you know
you're also bad at knowing when you're
bad at it
okay so what's the goal the goal here
formally is to construct some set family
corresponding to uh you know which Pages
your first friend reads which page is
your second friend reads and so on and
there you know they're provided by each
size R and some way to combine all of
these answers
so that if you combine the answer from
your first friend the answer from your
second friend the answer from your third
friend all the way on
that you're always going to get the
correct answer for any possible question
all right and just to make it a little
bit more mathematically formal let's
give some bound on the parameters and
let me try to justify this a little bit
so if n the the number of your friends
is less than p over r
then there's no hope of you winning this
game at all because your friends can't
even cover all of the the pages even if
they're destroying so certainly n needs
to be at least p over R and just to give
it a little bit of snack a little
slackness let's say n is that most uh
polynomial in P over r
it's our goal so yeah this is this is
this is the goal
and maybe you want to think about it for
a bit but uh
the only thing you can figure out is who
is consistent yes perfect great
do you get to ask multiple questions
before you combine or you just have to
do this what's the question yeah one
question at a time for every question
yeah there's no control over questions
it's just the you know the person's
asking you a question you get to ask
your friends and you better have the
right answer after Consulting with all
of your friends
yeah
after that saying on that story all the
discussions about the time
a covering argument
s
yes or no
and just to know that what is
yeah I guess I don't know the covering
argument is but maybe the answer might
be yes
sorry I'm sorry just a clarification
question so if I understand the question
Corrections
the number of questions per page is not
really important yeah it doesn't it
might as well just be one question for
me is that short is that right yeah
but you don't know but like the reason
I'm not equipping that is because you
should not be able to go from the
question to the page
ahead of time so you you and your
friends strategize to agree on these
sets s of I and this combine
so what you can do is like
um
preach possible page you can look at the
set of friends kind of the duel yeah
that are fancy which which sets T are
have the are monochromatic
yeah if you want to make sure that all
the monochromatic sets have to kind of
agree yeah so yeah you're both uh right
on the money here let me let me just
give the construction
um so what we're gonna do is we're going
to split up these pages one through P
into what I'll call chapters I'm calling
it chapters just for the book analogy
it's really just you know break it up
into blocks
um so that each block has a r over two
pages in it
maybe this parameter choice of R over 2
is a bit suggestive of what we're going
to do next
so what we're going to do is for each
pair of chapters we're going to assign
one friend to read that pair
so that is I can Define sets S Sub i j
or S Sub j i to be the union of the I
from the jth chapters
and for you know we can label Friends by
pairs of coordinates why not for the
ijth friend we're going to have them
read S Sub i j
so the first friend or the I2 the one
two friend is going to read the first
and second chapters the next one is
going to read the first and third
chapters and the
all the way all the way on
and as long as the number of friends you
have is more than 2p over R choose two
which is a polynomial in P over r
then you're going to have enough friends
to be able to at least read all these
pairs of chapters
so this this describes the the set
family but I haven't told you yet how
the how the combined algorithm works
yeah
that's exactly right so we're going to
do is uh you know we have to come up
with this combined algorithm
you're going to look at you know all
rows are all columns depending how you
how you see it it'll read over all these
chapters and look at this list of uh
answers from you know for for chapter I
you're going to look at the responses
from all of your friends who've read the
ice chapter
you're going to look at this list and
you're going to ask are all of these
answers the same is it a consistent list
and if it is output that unanimous
answer
so that's the full description of the
algorithm but let me analyze to make
sure this is even well defined
so so the analysis here
is that okay let's say there's some
question uh its page has to lie on some
chapter let's just say it's the the ith
chapter so I is now fixed to be the the
right chapter
for every other chapter or for every
chapter J
we know that the Q page is going to be
in you know in particular it's going to
be the union of the ithan Jace chapter
you know why not
so if you look at this list you know all
of these friends have read the ith
chapter so all of the answers are going
to be correct
so every single element in this list is
going to be correct
so in particular it's consistent and
it's consistent and you're going to
Output the answer it's it's going to be
correct
and you know just to make sure we're not
you know being uh we're not going too
quickly if uh there's some other list
that happens to be consistent for some
other J
then you know if it is consistent it
will also be all correct because one of
the elements in this list was the friend
who read both I and J
and so because the ijtha response is
going to be correct and the whole thing
is consistent you're going to Output uh
the right answer coincidentally
yes that's the that's the full
description of how this works
let me move to meta complexity land a
little bit
as a corollary
um if you have a promise problem Pi
that's going to have a nc0 menu and
reduction to uh Gap mktp let's say but
some con super constants multiplicative
Factor
then the zero certificate complexity of
Pi whatever that means is uh is
sublinear
and you know if you're unfamiliar with
uh with these terms maybe this will be a
little bit more clear
in particular we can show that parity
has no ac091 reduction so now we're
talking about ec0 reductions not nc0
reductions
uh to the same problem
and uh just another way another
consequence of this is that this uh you
know Omega one factor approximation to
mktp is provably unconditionally not NP
hard under many one ec0 reductions
solution
other non-uniforms
additional modifications
okay so let me give a proof of the
second corollary given the first
corollary so I haven't proven the first
quarter yeah but let me let's prove the
second one as a consequence
to say that we did have such a such a
reduction for contradiction
then you can apply random restrictions
to effectively make go from an ac0
reduction to to an nc0 reduction
and now you have a reduction from parity
or not parity
um to to this this mktp problem
but now we can just resort to our first
Corollary
that says you know that would imply that
parity would have sublinear zero
certificate complexity but parity has
you know totally maximal zero
certificate complexity so so we get a
contradiction
okay so now let me uh talk about this
first corollary and sort of how it
connects to everything I talked about so
far
so let me you know because I haven't
defined cap the Gap mktp formally and
the zero certificate complexity let me
just sort of try to get the ingredients
across of how this proof works and not
you know not the full proof
so you know if this weren't true then we
have some nc0 reduction
if you unwind the what it means for you
know what zero certificate complexity
means we're going to get some no
instance X of Pi and therefore if you
feed it through the reduction you're
going to have a string of high KT
complexity
but you're also going to get many
related and I'm being a little bit vague
but related yes instances so if you feed
it through the reduction you're going to
get some small description uh for these
uh for the results uh that fed that are
fed through the through the reduction
and our goal is to get some small
description for R of X which would be a
contradiction because we know that R of
X has high KT complexity by the
correctness of this many one reduction
what we're going to do at a high level
is we're going to think of questions as
being indices of the uh of this string
of this output string from the reduction
and the corresponding answer to that
question as being whatever you know that
index is for input X through the
reduction
and roughly speaking a page we'll think
of that as the corresponding set like
corresponding constant size set of input
indices you care about for the elf
output bit and this page you know makes
sense because we're talking about nc0
reductions so every output bit is going
to only depend on a constant number of
input bits
and now you know the implementations of
these you know weirdly you know helpful
or not helpful friends are going to be
implemented by these small descriptions
d sub K we have from the promise that
these uh you know y sub K are yes
instances and so they have a small
descriptions
and if you just turn through exactly uh
our arguments that we gave for the for
the game show
if you use these friends F sub IJ with
their you know with their
implementations d sub K and you use our
combined algorithm that we talked about
this uh unanimity uh checking then
you're going to get some small
description for R of X which is a
contradiction with the fact that R of X
we assumed has high KT complexity
let me let me finish up by uh talking
about a lot of the reason we're all here
you know Eric is Eric allender's day so
just personally speaking
my interests and uh and many others in
this field is really only possible
thanks to thanks to Eric allender
and you know let me just focus on you
know today we've heard many examples of
you know how he's been a leader through
the fields but I'm going to talk about
you know a little more of a you know my
personal case so I attended the the
dymax ru uh a few years ago uh with uh
with Rahul alongo and we looked a little
bit different back then admittedly than
than we do now
but um
yeah so so what is this dimax are you
it's a summer research experience for
undergraduates and this takes place at
dimax at Rutgers University and uh I do
want to emphasize that there's
undergraduates that we're talking about
and Eric has mentored you know many many
students over the years on meta
complexity projects throughout these
Summers and uh you know here's here's a
here's a list of all the students that
uh
uh that uh that Eric has mentored
through these Summers and maybe you
recognize a name or two
um but yeah I I you know uh sort of
echoing what Rahul alango was saying
earlier like uh you know Eric has been
extremely generous with his time
especially to undergraduates and getting
them started in meta complexity and you
know getting uh getting started on these
on these research projects and this is
the reason I've been interested in the
field and and it seems like other people
as well from the earlier talks today so
thanks so much for the organizers for
letting me talk on this day and uh
thanks so much Eric gallinder for
everything that you've done
[Applause]
foreign
I believe there's a reception there's a
reception outside for Eric's day
um so outside meeting outside the
building
yeah
is there a picture or uh oh yeah
so I think rahul's idea to get a
calendar and all the what was the name
allender rights
um do you have a picture group picture
so everybody was like
who feels like everybody